VERY MUCH, MY FRIEND I WANT TO
GO TO PENNSYLVANIA SENATOR BOB
CASEY, DEMOCRAT.
SENATOR VERY GOOD TO HAVE YOU
HERE.
I’M WONDERING HOW THIS BATTLE
BACK AND FOURTH ON THE STATES,
SENATOR, AND THE COUNTS AND ALL
OF THAT IS AFFECTING OR  COULD
AFFECT WHAT’S GOING ON IN THIS
GEORGIA RUN OFF RACE, TWO
RUN OFF RACES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL, NEIL I THINK THE
GEORGIA ELECTIONS ON JANUARY 5 O
STAND ON THEIR OWN.
THE RESULT, THE PRESIDENTIAL
RACE IS GOING TO BE CERTIFIED
SOON, AS YOUR CORRESPONDENT
INDICATED AND THE PENNSYLVANIA
RESULTS WILL BE CERTIFIED ON THE
23RD, BUT OF COURSE, THERE’S
A LOT AT STAKE IN GATHERING GARY
COHEN RACE IS BECAUSE IF OUR
SIDE IS ABLE TO WIN BOTH IT’LL
BE A 50/50 TIE AND WE WOULD THEN
HAVE A MAJORITY, BECAUSE OF THE
VICE PRESIDENT, SO, THAT’S A
SIGNIFICANT FIGHT AND IT’S GOING
TO BE WEEKS OF BATTLE, BUT I
THINK OUR SIDE HAS A REALLY
STRONG FOUNDATION NOW THAT JOE
BIDEN WAS DECLARED THE WINNER IN
GEORGIA.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, WE HAVE NOT
CALLED THAT RACE IN GEORGIA
OURSELVES, OTHERS HAVE NOT BUT
YOU’RE QUITE RIGHT.
HE LEADS IN ALL THESE VARIOUS
COUNTS BUT HAVING SAID THAT,
SENATOR, I AM CURIOUS ABOUT WHAT
JOE BIDEN WANTS, YOU TWO KNOW
EACH OTHER OBVIOUSLY VERY WELL,
I’M JUST CURIOUS AS TO WHAT YOU
MAKE OF WHAT HAPPENS, IF YOU
DON’T TAKE THE SENATE, THAT YOU
LOSE BOTH OF THESE SEATS AND
THAT IS DEMOCRATS, OR  YOU SPLIT
, WHICH AGAIN, WOULD
WOULDN’T BE GOOD.
SOME ARGUE THAT JOE BIDEN
ACTUALLY PREFERS THAT RIGHT NOW
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T WANT TO CAVE
TO SOME OF THE PROGRESSIVES IN
YOUR PARTY MANY OF WHOM ARE
DEMANDING THAT YOU GET BERNIE
SANDERS IN THERE, LABOR
SECRETARY, ELIZABETH WARREN AS
TREASURY SECRETARY AND HE
DOESN’T WANT TO GO THAT ROUTE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL NEIL, I THINK THAT IT
CERTAINLY, DEMOCRATIC SENATORS
AND PRESIDENT-ELECT BIDEN WANT A
DEMOCRATIC SENATE I DON’T THINK
THERE’S ANY QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
NOW, HE HASN’T TOLD ME THAT BUT
THAT’S I KNOW HIM WELL ENOUGH TO
SAY THAT BUT I THINK IF IT
DOESN’TT GO IN OUR DIRECTION, AN
IF IT IS A CONTINUATION OF THE
REPUBLICAN MAJORITY, WE’RE
GOING TO HAVE TO GET A LOT DONE.
THE TWO BIGGEST CRISIS IN THE
LIVES OF MOST PEOPLE ARE
WHAT YOU’VE BEEN COVERING THIS
MORNING, THE VIRUS, THIS
RAGING VIRUS WHICH IS
HITTING A RECORD NUMBER OF CASES
EVERY DAY, HERE IN PENNSYLVANIA,
THE CASES ARE WAY UP.
WE’VE SET DAILY RECORDS AS WELL.
WE GOT MORE THAN 9,200 PEOPLE
DEAD IN OUR STATE, AND SO IT’S
RAGING EVERYWHERE, NORTH AND
SOUTH, EAST AND WEST SO THAT
CHALLENGE IS IN FRONT OF US AND
THERE’S, IT’S A CHALLENGE BOTH
PARTIES MUST CONFRONT, AND THEN
THE JOBS CRISIS, THE ECONOMIC
CRISIS.
WE GOT MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
PEOPLE OUT OF WORK IN SEPTEMBER,
518,000, SO, WE NEED A JOB
STRATEGY AS WELL AND I THINK
THAT’S TRUE OF BOTH PARTY, SO,
WE’RE ALL GOING TO HAVE TO WORK
TOGETHER ON THESE TWO CRISIS.
I WOULD NOT WANT TO BE A SENATOR
WHWHOSE STANDING IN THE WAY OF
DEALING WITH THOSE TWO CRISIS.
NEIL: LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT THAT.
YOU ARE, SENATOR, RIGHT NOW IN
PENNSYLVANIA VERY INFLUENTIAL
ONE AND WE HEARD FROM THE
PRESIDENT-ELECT’S HEALTHCARE
TASK FORCE, WHO RAISED THE
POSSIBILITY OF A FOUR TO SIX
WEEK LOCKDOWN.
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF, HAS NOT
ENDORSED THAT NOR HAS HE REJECT
ED IT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT THAT, A
FOUR TO SIX WEEK LOCKDOWN
MANDATED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> WELL NEIL I DON’T THINK
THAT’S LIKELY TO HAPPEN, NUMBER
ONE.
NUMBER TWO IS THE REASON I CAN
SAY THAT IS BECAUSE WE KNOW A
LOT MORE ABOUT THE VIRUS THAN WE
DID BEFORE, EVEN THOUGH THE CASE
NUMBERS ARE HIGHER THAN THEY
WERE IN APRIL IN A LOT OF PLACES
AND IT IS RAGING, WE KNOW A LOT
MORE ABOUT HOW TO DEAL WITH IT.
LOOK, IF TENS OF MILLIONS OF
MORE AMERICANS WERE WEARING MASK
S, THAT ALONE WOULD TURN
THIS IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION, SO,
I THINK THAT --
NEIL: DO YOU THINK A MASK
MANDATE IS IN ORDER, SENATOR?
THE GOVERNOR OF NORTH DAKOTA IS
KICKING THAT AROUND BUT GO AHEAD
>> PERSONALLY, I THINK THAT’S
GOING TO BE NECESSARY IN SOME
PLACES BUT IT SHOULDN’T REQUIRE
A MANDATE.
IF YOU’RE A PATRIOTIC AMERICAN,
YOU CARE ABOUT YOUR NEIGHBOR,
THE PERSON NEXT TO YOU, AND YOU
CARE ABOUT YOUR OWN HEALTH OF
SOMEONE IN YOUR HOUSEHOLD, YOU
SHOULD WEAR A MASK AND THE GOOD
NEWS IS MOST PEOPLE ARE WEARING
MASKS, AND THEY UNDERSTAND HOW
VALUABLE THAT IS TO TURNING THIS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION, BUT
I THINK WE KNOW A LOT MORE ABOUT
HOW TO CONTROL THIS VIRUS, BUT
WE NEED A STRATEGY ON TESTING,
THERE’S STILL NOT NEARLY ENOUGH
TESTING.
WE GOT TO GET FASTER RESULTS ON
WE NEED MORE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT, ALL OF THIS IS
PLAYING OUT IN LARGE MEASURE IN
NURSING HOME, NEIL.
YOU KNOW THAT MORE THAN 91,000
PEOPLE HAVE DIED IN NURSING
HOMES WHEN YOU ADD UP THE
RESIDENTS WHO DIED AND THE
WORKERS.
WE GOT TO TURN THAT IN THE RIGHT